I want you to meet Logan Logan this is
my best friend Lea hey nice to finally
meet you nice to finally meet you too oh
the Oh more girls has got a blast and
those four scripts it's 90 minute movies
on Netflix and they're incredible and
they're done by Amy sherman-palladino
and Dan Palladino it's their show they
created it and they're directing all the
episodes so it just feels right it feels
like a gift and it's really come from
the fans since the beginning of 2007
with the show ended really and so it's
been that many years in the making that
this has happened and the fact that it's
come together feels really really
special for all the cast all the crew
and for the fans as well so it's good
I've been told I can't say much at all I
can tell you that that all for the
scripts are fantastic Amy
sherman-palladino and Dan Palladino did
an amazing job as to where the
characters are where they've been and
where they're going and they did an
amazing job of those scripts I'm blown
away by their work